attention bonjour julie salut casimir
qu'est ce que fait que ce chapeau et
cette can
mais ça sur ta tête pour voir le lac
anosy
mais non tu sais tu es super va way dis
moi pourquoi est ce que françois est
fâché mais lui pas fâché il ne m'a même
pas dit bonjour tu sais quand il
travaille il n'entend pas ce qui se
passe autour de lui
ah oui les sourds mais non mais il est
tellement intéressé parce qu'il dit que
c'est un peu comme s'il était sourd ça
s'appelle la concentration
je dirais comme la non mais je vais
quand même aller lui dire un petit
bonjour douce morin tout doucement
bonjour enfin casimir qu'est ce qui te
couronne en fait tu es fou non
julie m'a dit que quand tu apprenais
quelque chose tu es tu es sourd alors
j'ai voulu te dire un petit bonjour et
20 heureusement que tu n'as pas voulu
crier
bon bah écoute casimir dont jour là tu
es content et maintenant soit gentil
laisse moi travailler bon d'accord
françois auque est-ce qu'il ya encore
les aimer tu as plus mon chapeau 1
ben oui c'était autre forme et alors bon
rien c'est tout bon au revoir au revoir
je ne savais pas que je te dérange et ça
non c'est pas grave casimir m'excuser
j'ai vraiment des leçons très importante
à trop bon excuse moi je t'avais dit oui
mais je ne savais pas que je le
dérangerait autant bon ben on répète le
dos ah ouais d'accord alors abattu en 3
4 3 bat là-bas d'apparat non je ne suis
plus prêt non non ce qui se passe
il n'a même pas eu ma canne qui est 30
soir je vais rien lui manquait non mais
c'est justement
bonsoir
au quasi mais moi je finis autant de
fâcher homme écoute c'est moi qui vais
me fâcher ya qu un ventre plat
l'histoire pour ne pas voir ma canne
non ce que junior je vends aucune
histoire simplement j'ai des leçons très
importante et très difficile à admettre
dans les têtes ans c'est pas vrai comme
en mai constitue et parce que ça ne peut
pas être ouvrages et pourquoi
mais parce que tu sais tout chaque fois
que l'on ne sait pas quelque chose c'est
toi qui nous l'expliquent alors tu n'as
pas besoin d' apprendre des leçons à la
bâtisse est mon pauvre casimir il ya
encore beaucoup de choses que j'ai
besoin d'apprendre et d'ailleurs dont la
vie tous les gens continuent à apprendre
et même les plus grands savants ne
peuvent pas tout savoir et quant à moi
[Musique]
gray savent c'est ce que je voudrais
l'inde
finirai mon petit ou très grand
j'aimerais
les fourmis les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
audrey
complet
on n'explique ses mystères je voudrais
être très savants connaître le secret
des choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants risqué at-il deviner ce qu'on
trouve au delà des étoiles il voit ton
parfois des lions des hommes des cigares
l'est moins dans les cargos et les
marchés tout heureux
les canards
là où d'un coup d'oeil les dauphins
l'est marceau qui sont de vrais papiers
peints
son
c'est
comme des poissons dans la mer je
voudrais être très savants connaître le
secret des choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants russe quelqu'un est une vie
n'est ce coup trouve au delà des épaules
ils voient qu'on parle pas des lions des
offres d'essai galles
[Musique]
c'est ce que je voudrais c'est
ainsi livrés
petits ou trop grands j'aimerais
notamment
[Musique]
non